oh oh my gosh oh and we're live wait one
second here oh this just happened we
were on we were
we were flirting
sorry everyone one second
as we come in here welcome aboard
everyone we're about to go live with
scott dickers
all we say right now
share this link before i bring scott on
i just want y'all to know we're about to
make comedy history today
so share this link right now
before we bring scott on that is your
one thing for this awesome free show
you're about to get
share this youtube link whether it's on
your facebook group whether it's on your
twitter
wherever it is
go click this fun share arrow
and let people know hey hot breath
versus altia
and we're gonna have a few people out
here we have michelle and james good to
see y'all and evelyn
hello hello
as people are coming in here
i do this weekly q a on this hot breath
youtube channel every single week at 5
00 pm eastern time
so do subscribe to this channel if
you're not subscribed yet we're all for
comics by comics here to help you all
level up and we got joan coming in now
bob kirk ryan okay we're cooking now
shouty we're cooking now
well with that being said
ladies and gentlemen let's go ahead and
welcome to the show here the one and
only
mr scott dickers everyone what's goodie
scott
how do you do it joel thank you for
having me oh it's so great to see you my
friend nothing like two white guys on a
live stream it's really nothing nothing
like white
barriers
and i like your cartoony lettering and
your new uh
framing this this art it's all very
slick and very fancy
and i'm very impressed
oh it's it's you know like we were
talking off air you know piece by piece
you know and this
these designs and everything were
actually designed by a member of the hot
breath versus martha luis she actually
helped us kind of get a new
um a little more of an exciting design
aesthetic going on here in the hot
breath of hers so
wonderful yeah it looks great
that's the best part about you know
having a comedy community is it's
creative people that do a bunch of
different things so
we all are like you do it's all about
being positive and supportive so it's
the more that we can do for each other
the more we're all gonna get out of it
you know
yeah it's not a zero-sum game and the
the old-school competitive spirit that
you sometimes would feel in comedy uh uh
is let's make it a thing of the past
dude i totally agree and i'm so excited
as i've now that the live shows are
coming back and i'm starting to get back
out on the road and i'm starting to get
into these comedy scenes and a lot of
these younger comics
are really nice and welcoming and
supportive and i'm seeing comics like i
was just in richmond and comics were
like hugging each other and they like
it was really it's really cool to see
because when i came up you know back in
my day 12 years ago
it was very negative and competitive and
cutthroat so i'm hoping you know people
like you and what we're doing here at
hot breath is just helping that
positivity shine through and not that
competitiveness
yeah oh i i love what you guys are doing
well we love what you're doing scott and
we're so excited
thank you very much
yes oh and jason jason def philippo
felipo good to see you he said focus
focus okay we'll focus
we'll focus my 80d can kick in sometimes
people are not here for mindless chit
chat joel they're here for actionable
intelligence all right so we're gonna
get into the actionable intelligence
then so if y'all have any questions feel
free to please post them in the live
stream here and as you are coming in
please do share this live stream as well
don't keep this a secret here because
we're going to be dropping some comedy
knowledge for y'all
so uh as we're catching up here scott
it's this is perfect timing because we
actually
we did a comedy author series recently
where a little while ago you were part
of it where we interviewed a bunch of
different comedy authors and i just
released them all as like a series on
our podcast and then just yesterday we
did like a review show of like
all right what were the big takeaways of
the of the show and things like that and
one of the ones that came up
was your note to my question i asked you
about like well what do i do if i don't
feel like writing and you were like oh
you don't feel like writing
oh
it's like well then don't be a comedian
you know it's like you got to be willing
to put in the work or you know just
don't complain about what you're not
doing basically
yeah if a farmer gets up in the morning
i don't feel like doing the chores and i
want to feed the chickens i'm tired
you don't have the option and the better
comedians think of it like farming you
get up and you do it whether you like it
or not it doesn't really matter
yeah i remember that conversation that
was a lot of fun
yeah is is that what your kind of your
mindset around your new podcast because
you're releasing it every week and it's
all new materials so was it something to
kind of spark your creative juices and
get you some accountability
exactly so i love accountability i've
always loved having a weekly deadline
where i have to produce
work
because yeah some weeks you're not gonna
be feeling good and you're not gonna be
feeling funny or whatever but
if i have a show where i have to be
funny or try to be funny for like 15
minutes it's just me in front of the
camera
then i'm going to come up with something
you know and i'll do my best
and i love that i love the energy of
that and i kept compiling these comedy
ideas i would have this list going of oh
that's a funny observation or oh that
could be a good bit or whatever
and then
with the pandemic i wasn't going out as
much
and
then
even when the pandemic came back like
college lecture series corporate work
has not really returned
in with full gusto
i figured you know what i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna do this and
yeah it's kind of a big lifestyle change
to to sign up to do a weekly tv show but
um
it's good for me it's good for me i need
it and so i'm yeah i'm doing comedy and
i'm doing little
skits and little goofs and impressions
and animation
uh just like throwing everything in the
pot and just trying to have fun and do
something that i might my whole thing is
i don't want to just do what everybody
else is doing so i'm just doing
something that feels very me and
that just like
is a way for me to
express my unique sense of humor and
hopefully it connects with people who
have a similar sense of humor it's
obviously very different than going on
stage because you have no idea what the
audience is thinking
you know
did that most of my career i worked at
as a comic strip artist as a voiceover
artist and as an editor of the onion
never knew what the audience thought had
to had to make the stuff and then put it
out there and just hope and so i'm doing
the same thing now it's a little
different when you're performing it
somehow i don't know what what it is
about that but when it's you out there
and you don't have some facade of comic
strip characters or fake newspaper or
something else
you you do crave that
immediate response from the audience to
know oh did this joke work but i don't
care like i you know
like bill burr can do an hour podcast a
week where he just rants
and he doesn't care whether he's funny
he's just talking he'll talk about
sports for half an hour
so i can i can do that i can i can try
to be funny and
sometimes i hit sometimes i miss and
it's good like
the key to quality is quantity so the
more i produce the more really good
material i'm gonna have
and so whenever i
do have a chance to hit the stage
which i just for lifestyle reasons i
just don't do as much as i should
i have like this huge
catalog of material that i can draw on
that i've developed for the from this
show so it's kind of like my way of
forcing myself to write
i love it yeah that's that's how the our
daily writing club started like all
right 10 clubs started literally because
i was like oh my gosh there's a pandemic
i have no idea when or if i'm going back
to comedy if i don't have accountability
i'm not gonna write and it literally
started with me like
okay here's my webcam
i'm just gonna write for 10 minutes
here's what i came up with and then
people started participating organically
and it just evolved from there but it
all stemmed from i need accountability
to write or i won't
yep
how how smart how how much are you
because they they vary in length but
like how much how long are you writing
do you think per minute that actually
makes it or like you know what i mean
like kind of what's the ratio between
how much you have to create that
actually gets distilled down into like a
quality
product yeah so i would say i write for
you know a good solid work day which for
a comedian is about four hours
um
four hours
per show and i have some help i have
some people
who send me prompts and send me ideas
and
i'm getting the hang of having writers
it's tough to have somebody write in
your voice
because they'll send me 25 ideas and
there might be one idea in there that's
like oh yeah i think i can work with
that and then i'll just change
but
it really does help me to have that
to have have writers
so
and also it helps me like
get an idea of whether something's funny
because then at least i have some other
people involved if it's just me in a
vacuum i just i think there's a very
small number of comic geniuses in
history who
can come up with something funny
in a dark closet by themselves and
present it to the world and have it work
i think almost all of us all the rest of
us need to
run it by some other people or get some
kind of feedback in a group situation
writer's room situation
so yeah that does help me
i love that i've thought about doing
that with hot breath as well of like
getting like a a team of writers
together that wants to maybe like start
creating original content and stuff so
it's it's i mean
people want to write people want to
create so just give them an avenue to do
it so that's that's very inspiring
yeah and you've got a a podcast that's
uh of some repute so you'd give people a
platform you know you could have a
little
spot on the show where it's like you
know
somebody could send in a bit somebody
could send in a video or
yeah that'd be amazing
interesting well maybe this maybe maybe
people not breath versus will that hear
this i want to um
help take action the idea is the easy
part it's like you have ideas all day
but it's like which one do you pick and
then which one do you see all the way
through you know because i i can
i can go all day on ideas
i learned that a long time ago that it's
the execution is the
commodity because like if you go and
pitch an idea for a tv series in
hollywood
you're one of 50 people that pitched
that exact idea that day you know
how about seinfeld in a mortuary you
know and so
whatever it is
and
the people who can actually
write the script produce it make it work
like that's 99.9 of the work right there
i love it awesome and we've got some
great questions are you coming in so
thank you everyone for hanging out with
us here
and uh sketch my story just hit us with
a super chat so let's hit
super chat to hit him with a little uh
our we call that our share horn let me
turn that up a little bit that's
that's our share horn for uh people that
share a little love on that super chat
thank you so much sketch my story
sketch my story does animation over on
their channel we've talked about doing
some things together as well so thank
you so much um
so
the first question i'm seeing here my
friends is from drew beekler
and his question here is what are some
best practices for expanding on a topic
you have one or two jokes of but would
like more
that's a great question i was it's so
funny i was actually just working on
that an answer to that question earlier
today i'm making a video for my how to
write funny youtube channel
about how to use the funny filters so
i go through the basic process of
how to come up with a joke
start with subtext
and then take that subtext which is just
a flat opinion doesn't have to be funny
and run it through one
of the 11 funny filters then the next
one then the next one so you run through
all 11
and i started with four example subtexts
and as i would go through the funny
filters i would come up with different
jokes
with the same subtext but using
different funny filters
and it starts to sound like a bit
because you start with one joke you do
an irony joke and then you do a
hyperbole joke and that escalates it
then you do a mad cap joke and that
escalates it in a new direction
so if i had like two jokes
in a bit
i would just start thinking of the other
11 funny filters and see
what i could come up with when i ran
that same subtext through the other
funny filters
i if these terms don't mean anything to
you
they're all uh
on my website how to write funny.com you
can download a free
like joke writing cheat sheet that
explains the funny filters and how to
use them very briefly
and they're explained in much more
detail in my book and in my courses but
it's pretty simple if you do comedy or
have done any comedy i think they come
pretty naturally like you you you start
to understand oh yeah that's why that's
funny because it's a it's one of these
11 funny filters
and
that's how
most bits in stand-up work they just
play the same subtext but through a
different lens a different funny filter
to give it like a different flavor a
different twist
uh or what have you
very nice yeah and i will um i will find
that link
and uh share it with the peeps as well
so they can get
uh access to that because i think sketch
my story just said they
um oh i watched scott's video and got
his free checklist to coming up with
jokes right
yeah that's it
very exciting that's the one is it
linked to one of your youtube videos are
you set on how to write funny
i think it's in the description of
almost every recent video yeah beautiful
awesome all right so i'll i'll go grab
that for peeps and uh we're going to
keep the questions rolling here um
ryan skrilla asked what do you do when
you're in a writing slump
you know the answer to that one
you right
basically
yeah no i i i'll go back to the uh
farmer analogy again what if what if
you're in a cow feeding slump
do you just let the cows go hungry
or do you still feed them
yeah
but that's the hard answer
[Laughter]
nobody ever said this is going to be
easy so here's the um
here's here's the explanation of of
why that works okay so
and we talked about this before but it's
worth repeating
when you feel like you're in a slump and
you don't feel funny and you write
anyway the material that you come up
with is no less funny than the material
you come up with when you just feel like
you're on fire and you're in the zone
only you can tell the difference because
you feel bad about it your perception
clouds the whole thing
but the audience has no idea they don't
they can't tell they don't know
you have the same odds of producing
genius work either way so just keep
producing
you know write a lot of ideas and just
put them aside and look at them later
and you'll find a few things in there
that that are workable that you can
probably finesse you know
yeah i think it helps me
to just realize
like one everyone everyone struggles
with it i mean it's like i've had some
comics 30 years into comedy who are like
i still have to like force myself to
like sit down and do this like it's it's
difficult for everyone it's the people
that actually do it are the ones that
actually make the difference
so and most of what you write isn't
going to be kept anyway so lowering the
bar really helps me to know let me just
get it out there and maybe i'll find
something today
totally
yeah i think one of the most damaging
myths in all of comedy is that there are
certain people who are just naturally
funny and everything everything they say
think or write is funny
you know the good comedians make it look
like that
because that's because we don't see
the long hours they put in writing and
throwing away jokes we don't see their
team of writers who write jokes for them
and give it to them if they're like a
big name comic and they have writers
you know like stephen colbert gets up
and does a monologue at the beginning of
his show and that's
12 or 15 harvard educated comedy writers
some of the best people in the business
some of the smartest people in the
business locked in cubicles nine to five
all day coming up with jokes so they've
got hundreds of jokes so if you want to
compete with that you gotta at least
write a few a few more jokes you gotta
at least write 20 or 30 jokes to get one
joke yep you know yep yeah
beautiful
awesome and the next question we have
there i hope that helps you there ryan i
hope that helps other people that it's
just yeah just doing it
uh and i like the analogy of like
writing being a muscle that it's just
like the more you do it the stronger it
gets but if you don't you know then it
does atrophy and it gets even harder to
actually get back over that hump
yeah i think of that for almost every
type of comedy not just writing but also
performing and doing any other medium of
comedy i think
being on camera is a muscle
being on a mic is a muscle
working in a different medium is a
muscle like writing an article versus
writing a stand-up bit
and so i always recommend that people do
it all
otherwise you're one of those guys at
the gym who only works biceps ah i like
that yeah you want to be one of those
people
because let's let's say you got a tv
deal
you know
you're going to be the star and
head writer
you know whatever executive producer of
your show
you want to have all these other skills
pretty well developed so that
you're a good manager you're good boss
and you can you can step in you can give
good advice to people in the sound
department people you know doing
costumes doing the other actors you know
you just
you're not prepared for opportunity
unless you've developed all these
different muscles
kaboom
uh michelle
michelle malizaki who i believe was the
first person here as well so it's great
to see you
michelle
her question here
i guess i could bring them on the screen
too i guess i could we could be friends
look at that we could be fancy with it
she asked um i tried the digital and
non-digital catalog i got my premises
jokes etc but how do you organize them
that has changed a bit over time and
what is she talking about just for
people that may not know
i think she's i mean i don't know her
but i'm assuming she's talking about how
to organize all the jokes that you have
written
oh i thought digital non-digital catalog
was something that you have or offered
or something oh no i think she's saying
she has tried you know
uh organizing her jokes in a computer
versus paper that's what i'm assuming
okay yeah and so
yeah i would avoid paper like the plague
but you know whatever works for you
[Laughter]
i have so i have been for a long time
i've kept a document that's like my
brain dump and if i come up with any
observation that i think is amusing i'll
just drop it in there and then when i'm
writing i can go look at that and it'll
spark oh yeah i remember that
observation that could work now um there
are there are professional comedians who
say that's a bad idea you shouldn't do
that because
if it's a really good idea you'll
remember it but
i i think even an idea that may not be
good right now could turn into something
good and you always want to be writing a
lot so i don't ever really throw
anything away it's rare i throw away an
idea but i have this main dump that i
put everything in and then every once in
a while i'll organize it especially if i
come up with something i think is
especially good
i'll organize it in a separate place
depending on what i think it's going to
be used for it's if it's a stand-up joke
it goes in that folder if it's a movie
idea it goes in that folder book idea
different folder etc etc
and then so everything's organized by
project type
that generally helps me quite a bit
premises and jokes
i ca i just keep all my premises and
jokes bundled together
depending on what medium they're for
because i know when i sit down to
actually produce
something whether i'm writing stand-up
or
humor article or
let's say a script for something
i know there's not going to be like
notes that i'm going to be able to crib
verbatim i'm going to be basically
starting from scratch but i just want
you know what i want is i want someone
else in the room with me so what who i
get is me from a few weeks ago when i
wrote down all these ideas
that way i'm looking at something that's
not just me alone in my brain
so
that's that's how i do it that's how i
organize it and you know everybody's got
to have their own system that works for
them
but michelle you asked and that is how i
do it
hopefully that can help you figure out
what works for you
yeah and you know that was a big
takeaway from the comedy author series
we did is we tried to
we do all of them and then pick up on
common themes and one of the big themes
we found is it's like
here is a way to do it but it's like
what works for you may not work for
someone else or like
what p some people only may like be
um
like attracted to so like you have all
these funny filters for example but some
people may only have an intuition for a
few of them and that's how they hammer
out jokes you know it's just kind of
like
these aren't like in stone laws these
are like helpful guides but most of the
authors were like here's how i've seen
it work here's how i helped a lot of
people do it but it's also what works
for you and what's you're going to be
consistent with is what's going to help
you the most
exactly everybody's yeah everybody's got
to find their own way okay i don't know
where else oh i think digital versus
non-digital is where my brain went to
like it's whatever's most intuitive for
you but i will say as someone who was
non-digital
for all of my career and then the
pandemic hit and i started using google
docs
and like i now have one that is like
joke ideas i do have one that is like
new jokes i do have some that are sets
now when i go out to a show i'll still
have my set list that i write by hand
but
digital
if you can do it it's just more
searchable like if you're like oh these
things
you can search the topic and it's just
right there
that i would be dead without that search
ability and then with paper the reason i
mean i know i know a lot of people who
still just use a legal pad and they
swear by it
but
i would lose that like if you lose a
paper you're done for like that's i
can't even imagine that that would be a
tragedy so gotta have it in the computer
gotta have it backed up and it's gotta
be searchable in my opinion yeah and she
asked if there's any apps i mean google
docs is free i've heard people use
evernote before
i i yeah i am mistrustful of anything in
the cloud or online and maybe that's
just because i'm old but i'm just scared
that it's going to disappear if it's not
on my computer so i always save a
document on my hard drive oh so it's all
on your actual computers how you yeah i
i'm i'm skeptical of the
i mean i'm sure i'm just being silly i
i'm sure it would work just fine
and also i would have access to it
anyway but then so
another thing i've been doing lately is
i'm doing voice notes so i'll just do a
voice note of something
and then the way apple makes those and
how you download them to your computer
is extremely inconvenient
so i need to figure out a better way to
manage that but i do like that because
sometimes i think better when i talk as
opposed to write which i know a lot of
comics uh have that same
uh proclivity
yeah i mean what what was interesting to
hear
when we had mark normand on here was
like
he's a very meticulous writer so i was
like oh i bet he's very like
in the page and word for word but his
writing process is literally like
ranting and raving for an hour alone in
his room and then just picking things
that
found he found interesting or
potentially funny like it's a lot of him
just talking to himself like a crazy
person and then he'll like refine it
from there
yeah i have a lot of crazy person voice
memos myself
[Laughter]
so i hope that helps there michelle and
she said yes yes thank you beautiful
awesome oh yeah we're cooking now peeps
um
this is ahmed taha
okay this is kind of a a three i can't
he has like three three separate
questions so i'll just read it i can't
bring all three up at the same time he
says mr dickers
i admire your method in joke formation i
am an aspiring stand-up who is just
trying to deliver quality material
with
opening subtext in our country where it
is forbidden to talk about sex religion
politics dirty words but i struggle to
use your method my jokes come out not
delivering the subtext or delivering a
different one
all right well first of all my
condolences to you for living in such a
country i don't think america is far
behind
[Music]
so your your weapon is uh you have to be
subversive and you have to use
funny filters like analogy
where you can talk about shocking
subjects or
what did he say sex
yes sex religion politics or even like
dirty words yeah yeah
so
the way
that like the
the blacklisted people in the 50s in
hollywood wrote movies was
by being subversive and using analogy
to communicate their subtext so
there you can certainly use some of the
other funny filters but your analogy can
be like your foundation filters so
take your religion and come up with an
analogy for it
an example would be like instead of
people being adherent to a religion
imagine people being loyal to a brand of
of um
energy drink and tell all your jokes
about that
but map it to religion so people clearly
understand the analogy and oh he's not
talking about energy drinks he's talking
about religion
the state
is never smart enough to know that type
of subversive activity they don't get it
they don't get analogy so you can talk
about energy drinks all day and how all
these people are slavishly
you know they're they're
electing people who love this energy
drink and they're slavishly following
their
their rules and they're they're burning
people to steak who don't uh like this
energy drink etc etc etc
uh
everyone will know what you're talking
about
and you'll totally get away with it and
they'll also they'll think it's smart
because people think analogy is smart
makes makes you seem real smart and
there's nothing wrong
with
people you know perceiving you as
smart
uh
and i'm talking about when you
show that you're smart don't tell them
you're smart don't go up there and say
i'm smarter than you what i'm saying is
uh
if you're being clever in a way that
impresses them that's good for you you
know
nice well i hope that helps there ahmed
i'd be curious of where you
where you are
yeah is that saudi arabia
or uh where is that yeah i don't know
i'd be interested um me too
because what's cool about you know
building
online communities there's comedians
everywhere i mean basically all over the
world comedians have like reached out
everywhere except antarctica but we're
coming for you antarctica we're coming
for you there's a there's a very hot uh
alternative comedy scene in antarctica
i've heard oh
is there very hot i got what you did
there
so
i i really admire those comics in those
um
countries that don't have freedom of
speech
like i i that really like
hits me really hits me in my heart and i
just i i can't help but put myself in
that position and ask myself like what
would i do would i would i still
be bold would i would i push the
boundaries would i would i still be in
comedy at all
um because it just takes so much bravery
to go out there when you know you could
be disappeared you know
um
by just telling jokes it's terrifying
yeah and he he's in egypt he said egypt
okay
oh wow
that's rough
yeah oh we got okay we got some more
questions great question there on med
and uh if y'all are just joining us this
is hot breath we do weekly live q and
a's on this channel
and our guest today is mr scott dickers
so if you're here first time subscribe
stay awhile we have over 400 interviews
with comedians
all around the world all to help you
level up your game so
it's scott's a a friend and fan he's
been on the show a few times we always
love it and um
if we could take drew's questionnaire a
little bit deeper he does have a joke
example would you be interested in maybe
figuring out how to do it all right so
it seems to be a bit longer here um
teachers
wait do you can you read the comments do
you see comments
i do not see comments okay i don't know
i think if i click if i click the
comment button i can oh so yeah
i can i didn't know if it was easier for
you to read my brain kind of works
better when i read verse hearings so i
didn't know what would happen yeah so
i see
ahmed's
notes here where which one are you
looking at now uh this is drew beakler
there he is a teacher looked at me and
said hey you are not stupid you just
learn differently
and i was like i just said good morning
tag
oh so he has a poster for it do you see
the the one above it that says joke
example no example might be too late
teachers don't know how to talk to you
when you're in special ed class
they want to encourage you but it comes
off as condescending
teacher looked at me and said hey you're
not stupid you just learn differently
and i was like uh good morning
also you are the gym teacher
um okay so i see what what you're trying
to do here you're doing the misplaced
focus
funny filter which is where you try to
focus on something small and unimportant
and kind of ignore the elephant in the
room
and
drew's question before was if you
correct me if i'm wrong how to escalate
a joke into a longer bit when you just
have a couple of jokes
[Music]
so it's tricky with kind of a one-off
misplaced focus joke like that those are
kind of tailor-made for one-liners
because it's almost like you
you pull the rug out from under the
reality when you when you do the tag you
know because now we're in a totally
different scenario than we thought we
were
but
your basic subtext is
teachers talking to you
and trying not to sound condescending
and they have a hard time so i would
take that as the subtext making it
special ed classes whole different thing
if you were actually in special ed
classes i think that's interesting and
you could make a bit about that
because that's just funny and
embarrassing you know that i was in
special ed like that's that's
you're you're uh
coming out of the gate strong there
i would just start writing and riffing
on scenarios
with teachers and kids and what they do
what they say with each other i would
start coming up with different scenarios
where they could be together in class
during lunch on field trips
and the more jokes you come up with the
more you're going to start to see a
hierarchy of jokes and you're going to
see
oh this joke would be good to start with
this would be a better one to do later i
can escalate it
um when you start using hyperbole and
mad cap those are usually good for later
after you're you've like escalated a bit
but in the beginning you want to go with
just kind of the basic character jokes
irony jokes
analogy jokes
misplaced focus like this is good for
sort of a one-off
laugh line
but it's tough to expand that to a
longer bit like you know anthony
jeselnik every one of his jokes is a
misplaced focus joke almost everyone
and it's just he's a one-liner comic you
know he doesn't do a lot of long bits
yeah i mean a potential tag could be
their response like then the teacher
says something back to you or a student
then chimes in or
because it almost seems like the tag
being the gym teacher is the actual
punch line versus like good morning
being the punchline
agreed unless i'm missing yeah i see
what you're saying and and also
one one way you can prolong misplaced
focus a little bit is by continuing to
pull the carpet under for out from under
the audience so
also you were the gym teacher and then
one more line that
that
reconstructs the reality again you know
oh and also you are you are not a
student you are 30 you're not in high
school you know whatever just like keep
pulling the rug out from under mm-hmm
or maybe not the gym teacher they're the
janitor or it's like or the teacher's
like i'm not the gym teacher i'm the
janitor or you know something silly but
honestly what i look for when people
post jokes because we do joke feedback
on our uh live stream on every tuesday
people post jokes when we give feedback
and what i'm always looking for is like
what is personal in this joke what is
unique to this person so like you said
the special ed thing
if if drew was actually in special ed
i'm more interested in hearing material
about that than like oh this silly
misdirect about the gym teacher
exactly yeah i noticed that as well yeah
but thanks for thanks for bringing that
up there uh thanks for bringing that up
there drew i hope that helps you there
buddy yeah oh and he says he wasn't
special ed yeah so i i would yeah that's
that's a that seems like a gold mine
it's a gold mine go with that riff on
that come up with as many jokes as you
can about it
and a lot of the times when uh a topic
is personal and maybe a little
uncomfortable or vulnerable
we can try to hide behind like a silly
misdirect instead of just going to the
heart of it so i i have to struggle with
that as well where you kind of just
excavate these sensitive topics until
you get to the heart so i would say keep
digging deeper on your experience in
special ed and look deeper than just to
this like kind of it's kind of like a
get out of jail free card i was in
special ed but really they weren't a gym
teacher you know like tell us tell us
about you drew and your experience in
special ed and you're gonna that's where
you're gonna find the bit actually
expands
and i will say this too about
personal comedy i feel like a lot of
times
comics starting out almost use comedy is
like therapy and when you say get at the
heart of it to me that means
get at the jokes like stuff that's
really funny that the audience is gonna
find really funny and really laugh at
i worry sometimes about getting too
personal and too vulnerable in a way
that's uncomfortable for the audience
like you want to make sure you always
keep it funny
and keep it at a safe distance from the
audience so they're safe to laugh
and you don't ever get the ah
or the
or the that's you know the worst thing
is
yeah oh yeah for sure
you know and that is
that is a really good point scott
because i feel like a lot of young
comics
see someone like george carlin and
they're they're like oh i want to talk
about military industrial complex or
whatever and it's like we'll figure out
how to make your dog funny like let's
let's get
funny down first before you then try to
tackle all these things like i probably
spent
eight to ten years
making silly jokes before i was in like
all right it's time for me to like talk
about being like born in a trailer and
my family being like white trash like
things that are like
genuinely embarrassing to me that i've
just worked through
that i can now make material out of but
it was it took a lot of time of just
learning how to write jokes before then
i can then start making fun jokes out of
unfunny
circumstances yeah that that's kind of
the highest level of comedy is being
able to take really dark disturbing
subtext and turn it into
hilarity and it takes sometimes a more
seasoned comic who people know
for that to work and that certainly was
working for me at the onion this onion
is basically like a non-human comic that
people got to know over
decades and then they're a little bit
more of a safe place to be talking about
that stuff because they have this
foundation of
familiarity you know this person they're
not going to do anything surprising or
weird or make you uncomfortable but for
a new comic
it's a little tricky to go right right
to that stuff yeah yeah
so hope that helps there
hope that helps you there drew and chris
beasley said
he thinks the good morning line is
hilarious so do what you want as well
drew you know we're just giving you
feedback never works whatever works my
friend so
we're just here to give you the best
feedback we can at the end of the day
you say it on stage and if it works
there you go
um
i think but i will say this about chris
i think he's right like that line if
it's if it's said right it is a good
punch line it's like the teacher is
being very kind of saying now now johnny
you you know you really are drew in this
case uh it's not that you're not very
smart it's just uh that you learn
differently and then he's like i i just
said good morning yeah you know like
that's a pretty good pretty good joke
true that's true good point and then the
gym team
yeah yeah the gym teacher tag doesn't
even work for me if the if uh you really
hit that joke well
all right oh he says yep thank you very
nice and carol freeman keto carol she
made it she said so we can get started
now thank you so much keto carol
carol on the keto diet
yeah she has her own podcast i was on uh
because that's great i i have my own
struggles with sugar and i um i just did
a therapy session with her for the world
story i was like i eat too much cereal
but um
it's crazy man yeah just what what you
put into your body and how it affects
you physically and mentally it's just
pretty gnarly
but um yeah we can we can totally go
there joel if you want yeah
this isn't my zoom therapy session i
don't
no no i'm just saying that uh i agree
and
i so i got diagnosed with celiac disease
about 10 years ago 12 years ago
and went on the gluten-free diet which
is what you're supposed to do and
nothing really changed for me
and it was mostly because i'm old but
then they said
yeah i dug into it and i looked into it
and
it was the fact was i was on the
standard american diet gluten-free
version so it's not changing anything
still eating a lot of sugar and a lot of
like empty grains and stuff like that so
i switched about i don't know eight
years ago now
just
vegetables uh healthy fats clean meats
don't eat any processed food any sugar
night and day night and day in terms of
my energy in terms of
my
my health like i never get sick i used
to get sick all the time i get colds
like two three times a year really bad
colds gone totally gone you don't say
sugar at all or processed sugar like how
do you know i mean i will say this i i
do have a an occasional cheat meal
where i i indulge
but then i'm i yeah so for weeks at a
time i'm not doing sugar i hardly ever
even eat fruit
um and it's it's pretty amazing so
i'm uh i'm all about it carol wow
i mean scott seems like a good person to
come on your show carol um because
that's i i can tell
i've i've gone back and forth with sugar
and like taking breaks and when i take a
break dude like it's i mean it it's
literally night and day my mental health
is better physically i'm better i have
more energy than ever and then it's like
i feel amazing i'm never going back and
then i i'm a little bit and then you
know the dopamine hits and then my
receptors go off and then we're back to
husky joel you know so sugar is you know
they've done studies with rats where
it's harder to get a rat off of sugar
than cocaine yeah dude and they and they
go to the sugar when they have the
choice of cocaine and sugar they go to
the sugar
no it's it's legal
and it's legal crazy so yeah so uh yeah
i uh um relate to your struggle joel
whoa i mean that's encouraging to hear
the change you made long term and have
been able to sustain it because i go
back and forth with it you know
it's a lifestyle change like
it was easier for me because when i went
gluten-free
that i'm no longer able to eat out at
people's houses like i can't go to
dinner parties and eat anymore because
you got to have like a gluten-free
kitchen so it just made it easy to
control my food if you're if you're not
in that position it's a lot harder
because you're always getting invited
out hey you know meet me for a beer
whatever hey let's get a sandwich
you know bread in america you eat it it
just turns into sugar as soon as you eat
it so
uh it's a big lifestyle change and
people will think you're a kook
one of the prices that you pay
but um it's worth it in my opinion well
what's your vice how do you how do you
be bad
well like i said i do have an occasional
cheat meal i have a son he's 14 and
sometimes we'll go out and he's getting
a pizza and a brownie and um he oh by
the way he's gluten free too so we're
getting a gluten-free pizza and we're
going to get a gluten-free brownie but
it's still mostly sugar you know
and and my body can take an occasional
like every couple weeks having a sugar
thing it can take it but ideally i if i
go for weeks and sometimes even when i'm
with him i'll just eat what i eat you
know a bowl of pureed broccoli and he'll
eat uh his brownie or whatever pureed
broccoli like like broccoli soup you
just puree broccoli and yeah i eat all
my i just puree all my vegetables it
allows me to eat like an entire thing of
kale in one meal and i can eat it really
quickly wow yeah
dude your egg is the best love it i
could go all day on this i'm i'm about
i'm about it i know i we we got to go on
carol's podcast because that's the place
to talk about seriously yeah yeah that's
really cool to know though scott because
it is there is like seeing people that
achieve levels that like you have and
are
achieving i mean i i always love to hear
the operational side behind it that it
is like i'm doing all this but because
i'm able to like live at a higher level
that gives me more energy and optimism
because even when you eat bad then you
think bad and you feel bad and it's all
just like a cascade effect so it really
absolutely yeah and when i when i
started my new show like it was a big
production lifestyle shift and i did an
all-nighter probably once a week you
know for like 10 weeks in a row
and you know i'm an old man i'm nearly
60. so
you know the fact that i can still do
that um is is a testament to
how i take care of myself you know
yeah
it's a it's a super power it's like a
secret superpower to be eating super
healthy
it is yeah to be eating correctly like
eating what our bodies are eating
correctly it's just it's so easy to eat
wrong in america it's so they make it so
easy it's cheap it's available
you know and you go on the road and it's
like every exit is like oh my god the
crap you could put in your body you know
[Music]
yeah fidel said they've been off grains
for 13 years best way to get rid of
friends and alienate people
i'm telling you it is a huge lifestyle
change that will um
it will frighten people it will yeah did
you kind of go off and then like fall
back on and then was it kind of like a
process or were you like lying in the
sand this is now what i'm doing
well i experimented i love that we're on
this topic it's fine um
i'm waiting for bruce's and i'm a joke
yeah but
i i experimented so i started with a raw
diet
and
that that was too rough for me like um
especially because i had the celiac i
was trying to heal my gut you can't do
raw food it just scrapes your gut
and then i experimented with
um i mean straight paleo i guess
okay and then i went on this like super
strict paleo which is kind of where i
ended up but this was all like
it's a it moves at a glacial pace i do
like a year on one thing and then a year
on another thing and
i did give up all sugar like including
fruit sugar any fruit any sugar of any
kind for three months at one point and
that takes real discipline but it was
amazing so after that three months
a strawberry tastes like an ice cream
sundae it's like your your level of what
is sweet
plummets and so a banana is like the
most amazing treat in the world
you know and i like that that's how it
should be that's how humans were
supposed to be
uh existing on this planet that stuff is
supposed to be incredibly sweet and
delicious it's not supposed to be a
chore to eat exactly exactly our kids
i'm not gonna do strawberries is real
you know
exactly wow that's so cool wow the more
you the more you know there
the more you know
all right so um back to your questions
my friends here for the next few minutes
um
this one was from mark
clingman
oh wait no that's a meme example i think
you had a question about memes oh here
it is have you ever focused on creating
shareable materials such as memes rather
than jokes
well
uh i'll answer that one
i i started as a cartoonist which was
what they used to call memes before
memes
because they're just a picture with some
drawing
and so yeah i did that for many years
and then i sold t-shirts with my
characters on them with like a slogan so
that was kind of a pre-internet meme
but i have not really done that much in
the computer because there's really no
way to monetize that
i love that there's some people who have
like meme accounts you know yeah and
they
you know they uh uh collect memes and
are like um
what's the word not co-laters what is
the word for that aggregator aggregate
aggregators of memes
and you know you can build a following
doing that if you're really good at it
you really are up on meme culture
but it's it's really tough to monetize
the person who can
figure out how to monetize memes
is gonna do well because i feel like
memes are like the new comic strip we
don't we look at memes now that's it
used to be the the comics page people
would read it and they'd talk about it
now they're talking about memes you know
they're sharing memes for sure yeah and
there's some bigger meme accounts that
like get hired by companies to create
memes for them but that's like that's
like the one percent of people and memes
probably like tank sinatra or something
but most people are just creating them
for fun
it's yeah and it's it is a tough arena
to compete in i always like to compete
in the blue ocean i want to go where
nobody else is competing
so i can clean up oh i love your answer
was like
no cause there's no money
well we were talking about this before
comedy is not an art it's an
entertainment business
so i think it behooves uh somebody in
the comedy business to actually
make a living doing their comedy
and
i'm not gonna begrudge anybody who wants
to do it for fun and not make money but
i'm a professional comedy person so i
need to make a living doing what i'm
doing and i want to make sure that
if i'm like advising somebody to do
something
i want to make sure there's a a profit
model you know amen amen yeah we should
get paid for our work
and speaking of getting paid this one's
about a resume from tom vinson in
writing a resume for a writing job
what's the best way to include the
various pieces you've had published on
comedy sites just writing published in
251 or slack jaw
all right tom i can answer this because
i i did hire people at the onion for a
long time
and they kind of still do things the
same way
basically it's all about the submission
you're going to want the funniest
possible submission of headline ideas
and
news and brief examples
and if the onion is posting a job
they'll tell you exactly what to send
them
and you're going to want to you know
listen to those instructions and and do
it exactly that way but the reason 99 of
those submissions fail is they're not
funny enough
so
vet your jokes with friends
write a thousand jokes to come up with
your list of 15 so you can pick the
absolute funniest ones
and google them make sure the onion
hasn't done them make sure nobody else
has done them
make sure they're original
and get a lot of feedback especially on
your writing because when you write
those news and briefs
it people think that's easy to write in
an onion style but it's really tough
and
most people get it wrong
so practice and try it with people as
far as how to list where you've been
published in other sites
i would include that really briefly in a
cover letter and just say you've been
published in
251 in slackjaw
that's what i would do
nice what is 251 is that a humorous site
that i don't know about uh yeah i didn't
know what that i didn't know what either
of those were
slackjaw is a
humor website on medium
oh
okay yeah they're doing what we're doing
alex abaya is the uh
uh the editor and he's doing great oh
very cool
um
brent asked oh he said shout out to
antarctica and he asked favorite comic
to see try new stuff
for me that's bill burr because i like
the way he thinks and i like that he
tries out new stuff on his monday
morning podcast
and it's fun to listen to his thought
process and how
he he has um
obviously he's been doing it for so long
and he's such a master at it i love
hearing his mind go to the funny like
how he's how he seeks out the funny like
a heat-seeking missile yeah that's very
inspiring i love that
carol you like my books uh uh let me uh
be on your podcast to talk about food
helper she literally she came back on
and said what did i miss we literally
we talked about you for like 10 minutes
we literally
yeah i was wondering why she wasn't
commenting she like left as soon as you
came in carol we talked about health for
literally like 10 minutes
[Laughter]
awesome
um
joel i'm sorry can i answer one here oh
of course yeah yeah yeah which one are
you seeing
chris asks where is the blue ocean today
so yeah the blue the blue ocean
uh today is in all the new platforms
that aren't really hot yet
so you want to be on all those and try
those
and i try to keep my finger on the pulse
and learn about these new things so
there's a web 3.0
type of youtube
called um
soundsurf that i just got on and the
shareability and the find ability there
is really high
that's where you need to be so it's like
where tick tock was two or three years
ago people could go on and just you go
viral really quickly because
there were very few early adapters and
tick tock is still pretty good but it's
definitely on the wane
so i would say keep your eye out for
new platforms
anything you hear about from
a gen z person a teenager who's like oh
yeah i'm on this app where i'm doing it
jump right on that app you know though
those kids are walking
marketing consultants
and because they all talk and all the
kids do the same thing they're they're
terrified of being different from their
peers so you know if one kid is doing
something they're all doing the same
thing
so
get on those platforms and put your
comedy out there
that would be
my recommendation finding how do you say
like soundsurf is on web3 so how do you
even get on web three and i'm gonna show
you it's not as
web 3 is not a thing you get on web 3 is
the new so i'm learning all this stuff
i'm uh
i i'll pass on what i know but so web
1.0 was
you create a website you put your stuff
out there people can find it that was
the 90s early 2000s web 2.0 was about
the mid 2000s
late 2000s
where now you put your stuff out there
but
readers can comment on it viewers can
comment so you're now interacting and
there's this new thing called user
generated content that was web 2.0
interaction with the
audience web 3.0
oh yeah thank you uh that's the
interview i just did with jamar about
incredible
incredible thank you yeah yeah
and
web 3.0 is
taking that up one more level so now the
audience is not just participating they
are part owners in what you're doing so
in web 2.0
audiences would generate all this
content user generated content funny or
diet perfect example of
web 2.0 because people would upload
videos
and funny or die made all the money and
they got all the credibility and they
got all this opportunity to create
advertising and everything else
funny videos
but the users got nothing out of it
web 3.0 is where the users
can buy in can invest and they can
profit when
the creator grows
so it's very exciting and it's connected
with crypto so like nfts are an example
of web 3.0 when you buy someone's nft
and i know about this because i'm
selling this nft now
and when you buy that you invest in that
person
and if they grow the value of that nft
will grow
and so it's it's an investment you're
you're investing in their
business and their growth and i love
that because when i was doing the onion
one of the things i wanted to do was
make all the employees owners in the
company and i wasn't the business guy i
was the creative guy so i was never able
to make that happen try convincing a
business guy to give all the employees
all the money it's never gonna work
right but
the principle is something i really
believe in and for an audience like i
never even went that far i never thought
of having the audience be a part owner
but my god what a powerful thing to to
build loyal fans if they're actual
owners in what you're doing
everything they do is going to be
helping you it's going to be promoting
you and boosting you
because they benefit from it so it's a
very exciting development and
uh
yeah chris go to all the high schools
yeah and check out that interview
seriously because like scott goes super
deep even more into web three with an
expert in the space and talks about his
nft he just dropped um which you can you
can be a part of i think it's like it's
a just for like two more days though i
think
i think it's one word yeah
yeah so
it's uh
i should send you the link so you can
post that up here but yeah there's a ton
of benefit in that and that's what it's
all about it's about what utility you
get from buying it so
you hear all these stories of nfts
selling for millions of dollars and like
why do people have these apes or
whatever and that's really not what nfts
are all about they're they're like a
token
that is investing in the future of
somebody and the best nfts come with a
bunch of benefits and value so
i developed one that has all this free
stuff in it like free webinars about
podcasting and
cryptocurrency and a free ticket to a
comedy show and discounts on comedy
classes so it's like it's like a twelve
hundred dollar value that i'm offering i
see my screen has frozen i don't know if
you can still hear me oh here i'm back
there you are and
but if the nft costs 25 so we wanted to
make it a really easy entry
to this because it is you know asking a
lot you're asking people to go on this
this strange new platform
rally dot io and
spend 25 so it's it's a hurdle you're
asking people to make so we wanted to
make it as valuable as possible and then
in the future there might be more
bonuses so it's like once you own that
thing you own any bonus that comes with
it so
that's a part i'm sort of getting my
feet wet into this whole web 3.0 by
doing that and uh it's pretty
interesting
uh and just the final one just to touch
on real quick evelyn um because she's
been a day one og here at the hot breath
verse um awesome uh she said i want to
write funny songs do you have a starting
or conversion tip
to like start writing funny funny songs
i would say um
and i just posted the nft link if
anybody wants to check that out
um
i would say
listen find my podcast
with a weird al
because he really talks about
the down and dirty in the weeds process
of how you write a parody song and how
you write a funny song it was really
instructive
he uses like rhyme zone like he really
talks about the down and dirty
and
i am assuming you're musical
so you're going to want to write the
music as well as the lyrics
but
yeah just start writing songs you know
and i guess don't be afraid to suck like
if i don't know how much you've done but
don't be afraid to try some stuff it
doesn't work
and
experiment and put it out there get some
feedback and just adjust you know it's
how all comedy is done you put put some
stuff out there that you think is pretty
good
you get some feedback you adjust you
come back at it and then you get better
over time you know
kaboom
well ladies and gentlemen
of the hot breath verse
i mean
we've done it again cue the applause i
have put links to um
scott's i just pinned it to the top of
the live chat as well for his
uh that nft you can check out and check
out that interview he did seriously like
i've been trying to learn more about the
space and this is probably the most just
like informative and just to the point
what is it why how can we use it um just
the space the web3 space in general so
yeah jamar john johnson he's a like a
20-year stand-up comedy veteran
who really understands
web 3 and crypto and i had him on the
podcast to explain it because he was
explaining it to me in such a simple way
that i had never heard
before and i was like oh my god you're
making it so simple yeah i wanted to
share that
beautiful well well thank you for
sharing your time with us today scott i
mean is there is
is there anything else like you want the
world to know or anywhere you want uh
people to go after this or anything yeah
i want the world to know about my new
comedy podcast that i just started uh
with zero followers this is this is a
thing i like to do where i leave one
comedy venture and i start a new one at
ground zero
because it keeps me hungry
so that podcast is uh scott dicker's
around
and it's on all the podcast platforms
it's a video podcast so you can get it
on apple
and youtube with the video otherwise
it's audio i i feel like sometimes the
audio doesn't work because i do like
little animated skits and how can people
tell what's going on if they're not
seeing the animation but you know they
listen it's a it's a thing you know
blind people i guess are enjoyable
well i will uh i'll be sure to put that
in the show notes of this podcast as
well and for people watching thank you
yeah for people watching this live go
subscribe to that youtube channel i mean
legitimately scott
is one of the best comedy resources on
the planet so everything he's putting
out is of the utmost quality and that's
why it's such an honor to always have
them on here so go subscribe
and podcast
i appreciate that very much joel thank
you for having me and thanks everybody
who joined in
absolutely well go forth my friends if
you haven't subscribed to our channel
do that as well
and we will see you all next week right
here on another live q and a wednesdays
at 5 00 pm we love y'all
take care everybody
you